I've started taking HCl and Burberry for Hpylora. I was taking one Burberry with my
meals three times a day, but I noticed that the Burberry was making me incredibly
fatigued. I took it away for a couple days and continued the HCl to confirm. Is it okay if I take
the Burberry all at once after my last meal of the day? How do you suggest I take someone take it
for a current Hpylora infection? Burberry would be one of my favorite things to take for
an Hpylora infection. Burberry has other benefits as well. It's a great cancer killer
and it can help with other bacterial infections and even viral infections. It's one of my favorite
supplements. I haven't had a lot of people that have said that Burberry makes them
sleepy, makes them fatigued. It quite possibly may be the die-off of Hpylora, so Hpylora is a
gram-negative bacteria. Gram-negative bacteria, so you might have heard of gram-negative
bacteria when someone's referred to Lyme disease, too. Borrelia, burgodorphy, the bacteria,
Lyme disease is a gram-negative bacteria. Gram-negative bacteria are called that because they stain
with the gram-state, differently than gram-positive bacteria. The reason why they do is because they have
in their cell membrane, they have lipopolysaccharides, which is a long-chain
saccharide and that lipopolysaccharide will be liberated when they die. If for someone to get the
tea after taking Burberry, I don't think it's a function of the Burberry per se, but it's probably
a function that I'm just thinking this through. It's probably a function of the Burberry,
what could be two things? It could be a function of the Burberry actually killing Hpylora and liberating
lipopolysaccharides and giving the person a hook-siber reaction. So a hook-siber reaction is when
you produce a lot of endotoxins and most commonly it's through the death, the killing, the
lysis of gram-negative bacteria spilling tons of lipopolysaccharides into your bloodstream and then
your liver has to get rid of it. So when your liver is overwhelmed, getting rid of endotoxins, in this
case lipopolysaccharides, it can make you feel ill, almost foolish, just really tired. That's
what's called a hook-siber reaction. It's been defined as a hook-siber reaction. Lying people will
often say they got a hook's reaction, but that could happen whenever you're killing especially
gram-negative bacteria. So that could be a possibility that you're actually killing the Hpylora,
which is a good thing. So certainly yes, you could change when you take it, you could take it all
in the evening, you can play with that dosage. It's not necessary that you need to be killing
that bacteria 24-7. So certainly you can play with it. The other possibility is that Burberry does have
other physiological functions in your body, it could lower your blood sugar. So if the Burberry
is in fact lower in your blood sugar, causing you to have fatigue because you have hypoglycemia,
that's a whole other vault of wax. So if you have a glucometer, it would be a good idea to check your
blood sugar levels. You don't want your blood sugar levels to drop below 70, if they drop below
70, 75, but you're not trying to keep your blood sugar low, like in the case of cancer patients,
but if they drop down below that level, you can have fatigue and exhaustion because of hypoglycemia.
So that's another possibility, easily measured normally after your blood sugar levels up,
but then it's supposed to go back down to normal, not dipping down to a hypoglycemic state.
So do check that as well. If you do have hypoglycemia from Burberry, it's quite possible that you have
a level of hypoglycemia without Burberry that you might not fully recognize or notice. So having a
glucometer to check your blood glucose levels will be a good idea to be able to diagnose hypoglycemia.
Then the treatment for hypoglycemia really is going to be to not eat three meals a day,
but to break that up at the maybe six meals a day and have food in front of you all the time,
so that you can keep your blood sugar regulated. And where would you get a blood sugar checker
and glucometer? Well, you can just get that a target. I can prick your finger and check your blood sugar.
Pretty simple, but you do.